und damit kommen wir zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt da geht es um das
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz 2 die
Fraktionen von SPD Bündnis 90 den Grünen
und FDP haben hier ein Gesetzentwurf
eingebracht denn Sie möchten dass
Sanktionen effektiver umgesetzt werden
und dazu gehört unter anderem dass der
Immobilienmarkt transparenter werden
soll und auch unattraktiver für
Geldwäsche und
Steuerhinterziehung das bedeutet man
kann dann eine Villa nicht mehr mit
Bargeld zahlen oder mit Krypto Währung
auch Rohstoffe sind denn nicht mehr als
Gegenleistung möglich also so dass es
einfacher überprüfbar ist wer wann eine
Immobilie erworben hat und falls Ihnen
das
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz bekannt
vorkommt es gab das erste tatsächlich
schon Anfang diesen Jahres im Frühjahr
damals ging es darum dass sanktionierte
Personen aufgrund des ukra keine
Angriffs auf das Ukraine Kriegs ihre
Vermögen offenlegen nur das tun kaum
welche Christian Lindner in der
Bundesfinanzminister spricht nun als
erstes dazu
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Staat muss
stark sein mein Verständnis eines
starken Staates ist aber nicht dass wir
ihm immer neue Betätigungsfelder suchen
sondern er sollte stark sein im Sinne
von handlungsfähig und dies insbesondere
in seinen Kernbereichen dazu gehört ganz
elementar und zentral die
Handlungsfähigkeit des Rechtsstaates in
diesem Kernbereich
in diesem Kernbereich stellen wir
unseren Staat neu auf und beseitigen mit
dem
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz 2
handlungsdefizite im Zuge des russischen
Angriffs sind für unseren Rechtsstaat
neue und bisher nicht gekannte Aufgaben
hinzugetreten in breiter europäischer
Einigkeit haben wir umfassende
Sanktionen gegen das System Putin
verhängt wir beschneiden nicht nur die
finanziellen Profite der russischen
Wirtschaft und die finanzielle
Handlungsfähigkeit des russischen
Staatswesens wir nehmen auch jene auf
individueller Ebene in den Blick die aus
diesem autokratischen System ihren
ökonomischen Nutzen Zielen ziehen wer
Putin unterstützt der soll seine
Dividende nicht hier in der Sicherheit
der Demokratie leben dürfen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen dafür
haben wir bereits im Mai mit dem
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz eins ein
erstes Maßnahmenpaket beschlossen damit
haben wir den Zoll und die zuständigen
behördenrechtlich und administrativ in
die Lage versetzt ihre neuen Aufgaben
wahrnehmen zu können schon damals war
aber klar es braucht langfristig
strukturelle Verbesserungen damit die
Sanktionen wirksam durchgesetzt werden
können wir stellen den Vollzug jetzt auf
rechtlich umfängliche stabile Grundlagen
und wir schaffen gewissermaßen nach der
AD
hoc-krisenreaktion auf diesem Feld eine
neue gute Staatspraxis der geht eine
ganze Reihe umfassender struktureller
Reformen an und dabei steht eines im
Zentrum mehr Effizienz und mehr
Schlagkraft durch Digitalisierung und
die Bündelung von Kompetenzen der
Rechtsstaat muss besser organisiert sein
als diejenigen die Gesetze brechen
ihr Grund eine neue Zentralstelle für
die sanktionsdurchsetzung die die
Zuständigkeiten für die Ermittlung und
die Überwachung eingefrorener
Vermögenswerte ordnet diese Bündelung
von Daten und die koordinierte Steuerung
aus einer Hand nutzt Synergien und
beendet an leider bestehendes
kompetenz-gossene Verschlankung der
Verwaltung ein handlungsfähiger Staat
ist eben nicht groß und kompliziert
sondern schnell und schlagkräftig zudem
zudem nutzen wir die neuen Möglichkeiten
die uns die Digitalisierung bietet wir
verknüpfen die für die Klärung von
Eigentumsverhältnissen und
Vermögenswerten relevanten Quellen etwa
in dem die Immobiliendaten aus den
Grundbüchern in das Transparenzregister
aufgenommen werden und damit beenden wir
die Ära der Aktenordner und bringen die
Bekämpfung der Finanzkriminalität ins 21
Jahrhundert
wir gehen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir gehen mit dem Gesetzentwurf aber
auch über die konkrete
sanktionsdurchsetzung im Zuge dieses
angriffskriegs hinaus wir betätigen
weitere Hebel zur Bekämpfung der
Finanzkriminalität insgesamt zum
Beispiel war es mir persönlich während
der Verhandlungen über die Bildung einer
Ampelkoalition
ein Anliegen dass wir insbesondere
Immobilienbereich Möglichkeiten der
Geldwäsche beschränken damit ist auf gar
keinen Fall eine Pauschalverurteilung
verbunden und unverändert sind wir der
Auffassung das Bargeld einer gedruckte
und geprägte demnächst auch digital
verfügbare Form von Freiheit ist
allerdings eines ist zu bezweifeln das
nämlich alle diejenigen die eine
Immobilie mit Bargeld bezahlen wirklich
von freiheitlichen Gedanken geleitet
sind
diese Einschränkung liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen diese Einschränkung der
Freiheit Bargeld zu nutzen wird die
freiheitsbilanz unserer Gesellschaft
insgesamt nicht negativ beeinflussen
sondern eher dafür Sorge tragen dass
nicht die ehrlichen diejenigen sind die
von denen die Regeln brechen geschädigt
werden ich verrate kein Staatsgeheimnis
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
verrate keinen Staatsgeheimnis wenn ich
feststelle die Partnerinnen und Partner
der Ampelkoalition haben bisweilen
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen in der
Steuer- und Finanzpolitik aber in einer
Sache stimmen wir über ein und da kann
es keinen Zweifel geben uns einst die
Entschlossenheit zur Bekämpfung der
Finanzkriminalität wir haben einen
gemeinsamen Kompass Geldwäsche und im
übrigen auch Steuerhinterziehung das ist
nicht nur Betrug am Fiskus sondern das
ist Betrug an der gesamten Gesellschaft
die ehrlichen sollen den findigen
gegenüber nicht im Nachteil bleibt
so weit Bundesfinanzminister Christian
Lindner hier in der Debatte zum
sanktions durchsetzungsgesetz die erste
Beratung dazu Matthias Hauer aus der
Unionsfraktion antwortet nun direkt er
sitzt im
finanzausschusskoalition ist die
schlechteste Bundesregierung die wir je
hatten
und das zeigt sich auch bei diesem
Gesetz
es ist dringend nötig die Sanktionen
gegen russische Oligarchen endlich auch
in Deutschland konsequent umzusetzen und
was tut die Ampel erst lassen sie sich
monatelang Zeit dann legen Sie jetzt ein
völlig unzureichendes Gesetz vor und
wollen ihr Gesetz nun auch in Windeseile
durch dieses parlamentarische Verfahren
Peitschen das hat mit sachgerechter
Gesetzgebung überhaupt nicht zu tun
beim ersten sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz
war das parlamentarische Verfahren schon
unterirdisch die Ampel hat damals
versprochen dass das die absolute
Ausnahme bleiben würde und beim zweiten
wiederholt sich das nun die Ampel zeigt
damit auch Geringschätzung für den in
Deutschland reichlich vorhandenen
Sachverstand 100 Seiten hat der
Gesetzentwurf er schafft ein neues
Gesetz er ändert 21 Gesetze raten Sie
mal wie viel Zeit sPD Grüne FDP zum
Beispiel den Gewerkschaften oder den
Berufsverbänden gewehrt haben um diese
100 Seiten Gesetzänderungen zu bewerten
weniger als 45 Stunden also keine zwei
Tage und da gibt es einhellig natürlich
Kritik bei der Zivilgesellschaft also
beispielsweise schreibt der notarver der
Deutsche notarverein in seiner
Stellungnahme die Gesetze Frist von
anderthalb Tagen die zumindest in den
zurückliegenden 10 bis 20 Jahren
beispiellos sein dürfte lässt eine
seriöse Befassung mit dem Entwurf gar
nicht zu sie erweckt leider den Eindruck
dass eine solche gar nicht gewollt ist
und durch solche Aktionen macht die
Ampel die wichtige Beteiligung der
Zivilgesellschaft zu einer Fass aber
auch innerlich geht ihr Gesetz nicht
weit genug Deutschland ist bei der
Durchsetzung der EU-Sanktionen schlecht
aufgestellt man fragt sich ernsthaft
wieso sie jetzt ein Dreivierteljahr
gebraucht haben um dann dieses völlig
unzureichende Gesetz vorzulegen die
Ampelkoalition hat selbst einen
zuständigkeitswirr war herbeigeführt im
Mai haben sie noch beschlossen dass die
Bundesländer für die Sanktionen
Durchsetzung zuständig sein sollen wir
haben das damals schon als
schwerwiegenden Fehler bezeichnet und
wir haben damals vorgeschlagen dass der
Bund da die Zuständigkeit bekommen soll
es geht um sensible außenpolitische
Sachverhalte das gehört auf die
Bundesebene und werden sie damals schon
unseren Weg mitgegangen hätten wir seit
Monaten eine schlagkräftige Struktur aus
einer Hand
sie haben stattdessen darauf vertraut
dass 16 Bundesländer behördliche
Parallelstrukturen aufbauen um für diese
aktuelle Ausnahmesituation viele neue
Stellen schaffen und natürlich haben die
Bundesländer das nicht getan weil sie
der Bundesminister hat gerade gesagt
schon damals den Bundesländern gesagt
haben dass demnächst sowieso diese
Aufgabe beim Bund landen wird und so ist
wichtige Zeit bei der Durchsetzung der
Sanktionen verloren gegangen jetzt
wollen sie eine neue Zentralstelle
erstmal bei der Generation ansiedeln
aber auch das nur vorübergehend die
Ampel will also nach dieser
Übergangslösung eine Übergangslösung wir
sagen schaffen sie klare Zuständigkeit
mit einer zollpolizei statt immer neue
Übergangslösungen die Ampel will in 22
Gesetze diese sanktionsdurchsetzung
packen wir als Union wollen das Bündeln
in einem Gesetz die Ampel lässt
sanktionierte Oligarchen weiter in
luxuswellen wohnen in Luxuskarossen
rumfahren wir wollen das nicht wir
wollen stattdessen nicht nutzungsverbote
wir wollen
wer zu Putins Regime gehört und diesen
Krieg aktiv in der Ukraine unterstützt
der soll mit seinem Vermögen auch zum
Wiederaufbau der Ukraine beitragen
müssen
und die Ampel will bei Vermögen unklarer
Herkunft weiter weg sehen wir als Union
wollen dass zukünftig eine vollständige
Beweislastumkehr gilt wenn zum Beispiel
plötzlich beispielsweise bei einem
ehemaligen spd-chefhaushälter über
200.000 Euro im Bankschließfach
auftauchen dann soll der künftig
nachweisen müssen woher die Gelder
stammen dazu im ampelgesetz übrigens
nichts die Ampel will nun ein
barzahlungsverbot für den Kauf von
Immobilien das ist gut dass die Ampel
unseren Vorschlag dazu aufgegriffen hat
und wir unterstützen das natürlich
ebenso unterstützen wir auch die
hinweisgeberstelle und auch die Aufnahme
von Immobilien ins Transparenzregister
wir wollen insgesamt mehr Transparenz im
Geschäftsverkehr wenn bei einem
Unternehmen zum Beispiel überhaupt nicht
klar ist wer am Ende wirtschaftlich
Berechtigter ist dann soll ein solches
Unternehmen keine Geschäfte machen
dürfen und auch wenn Gesellschaften
Immobilien kaufen dann müssen deren
Anteilseigner verlässlich
identifizierbar sein auch wieso findet
sich im ampelgesetz nichts wenn Sie also
wirklich einen großen Schritt nach vorne
bei der sanktionsdurchsetzung machen
wollen dann sollten Sie den Punkt aus
dem unionsantrag unterstützen vielen
Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Matthias Hauer hier mit
deutlicher Kritik an der Koalition als
Ganzes Jan König wird nun auf jeden
Folgen er ist Mitglied
ja ein pardon Carlos Casper spricht als
nächstes für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit den
Überfall Russlands auf die Ukraine hat
die EU umfangreiche sanktionspakete
beschlossen über 1.000 Personen und
hunderte von Organisationen stehen nun
auf den Sanktionslisten der EU
das russische Regime soll eben nicht
mehr mit Oligarchen Gehältern den Krieg
in der Ukraine finanzieren das ist das
Ziel
aber das Thema Sanktionspolitik hat eben
noch in den vergangenen Wochen und Tagen
an Aktualität gewonnen während die
Bevölkerung im Iran auf die Straße geht
für den Demokratie streitet kaum Jobs
und kaum Perspektiven hat ist die Zahl
der Millionäre im Iran auf 250.000
angestiegen da müssen wir genauer
hingucken und ich glaube in den nächsten
kommenden Tagen werden wir auch dort
mehr sanktionieren
und was kann denn Sanktionspolitik
Sanktionspolitik kann
Demokratiebewegungen unterstützen
passende unter Druck setzen und eben
kriegerische Staaten den Geldhandel
zugeben aber damit das passiert müssen
wir eben auch Sanktionen durchsetzen und
das wollen wir verbessern mit diesen
Gesetz
es soll eben nicht mehr möglich sein für
russische Oligarchen für die
Herrschenden im Iran und eben auch für
Geldwerte hier so einfach Geld in
Deutschland um zu anzulegen in
Deutschland muss es ungemütlich werden
für diese Personengruppen und da haben
wir schon mit den
sanktions-durchsetzungsgesetz eins im
Mai einen wichtigen Baustein geleistet
wir haben den Datenaustausch verbessert
und eben auch eine nationale
Anzeigepflicht für sanktionierte
Personen beschlossen das war so richtig
dass sie auch EU-Ebene übernommen wird
und das ist ein Erfolg das
unternehmensvorreiter in Deutschland und
so muss es weitergehen
und dass die Maßnahmen schon gewirkt
haben zeigt ja auch das Beispiel an
Alicia osmanow russische oligars und
enger vertraute Putins den ist so gut
bislang in Deutschland gefiel dass es
sogar hier in Deutschland ein Wohnsitz
begründete und seine konnten wurden
beschlagnahmt seine Yachten seine Häuser
wurden durchsucht und so muss es
weitergehen ungemütlich für die
Oligarchen in Deutschland
[Applaus]
und mit den sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz
1 haben wir eben auch ein Versprechen an
die Länder gegeben wir begründen eine
bundeszuständigkeit und das ist dringend
nötig und wir brauchen eine Behörde die
ich die Sanktion gut durchsetzt wie
stark durchsetzt und schnell
handlungsfähig ist und das machen wir
auch mit diesem Gesetz
und die Länder müssen auch ihren
Verantwortung nachkommen wir brauchen
ein immobiliengrundbuch dass wir auch
zentral einsehen können was digital ist
und das soll eben noch neun bis 15 Jahre
dauern das kann ich niemanden erklären
da müssen die Justizministerin der
Länder endlich handeln und ihrer
Verantwortung gerecht werden
und das ist dahin soweit ist müssen wir
uns eben helfen wir verpflichten mit
diesen Gesetz die Notare die
Immobiliendaten anders
Transparenzregister zu melden damit wir
endlich einen Zugriff bekommen und
wissen wem hier in Deutschland welche
Immobilien gehören und außerdem das kann
man nicht zu gering schätzen und es war
mir der Union eben nicht zu machen in
der vergangenen Legislatur deswegen
finde ich ihre Rede Herr Hauer ziemlich
populistisch wir führen ein
bargeldverbot ein das ist super wichtig
wir sind da Schlusslicht in Europa und
das war eben keine Politik der Union das
war die Politik der Ampelkoalition die
die das ermöglicht und es setzen eine
Vereinbarung aus den Koalitionsvertrag
um außerdem werden wir für Unternehmen
mit Sitz im Ausland ist erschweren
wirtschaftlich fiktive wirtschaftlich
Berechtigte zu benennen
es soll eine hinweisgeberstelle
eingeführt werden und eben auch für
Unternehmen mit Sitz im Ausland
müssen jetzt Bestandsimmobilien auch die
Eigentümerschaft vorlegen wir setzen
viele weitere Bausteine noch um in
dieser Legislatur da bin ich mir sicher
und ich freue mich da auch auf die
Verhandlungen und ja wir brauchen auch
eine Möglichkeit
Vermögen unklarer Herkunft einzuziehen
und da wird es eng für Unionsabgeordnete
oder uns Abgeordnete es trifft nämlich
dann Unionsabgeordnete die gerne mal mit
Max und die ist sich die Taschen
vollschlagen das kann ich Ihnen sagen
mit diesen
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz leisten wir
ein effektiven Beitrag das ist hier
ungemütlich wird für russische
Oligarchen für Geldwäsche und Konsorten
und wir finden uns auf einen richtigen
Weg vielen Dank ich freue mich auf die
Beratung
[Applaus]
Carlos Casper war das und jetzt kommt
Jörn König er sitzt wie sein Vorredner
im Finanzausschuss ist im Mitglied der
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrter Herr Minister sehr geehrte
Kollegen und vor allem liebe Bürger die
ampelfraktion haben einen Gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt für die bessere Durchsetzung
von Sanktionen
Einzelpersonen sollen sanktioniert
werden um Druck auf Putin auszuüben
damit er seine völkerrechtswidrigen
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine beendet
diese Absicht des Gesetzentwurfes ist
klar und natürlich zu begrüßen
wir gehen aber davon aus dass in Zukunft
jeder Kriegstreiber jeder Nationalität
sanktioniert wird da wären als erstes
die Russen die den einen oder anderen
SPD genossen mit gute tierten Posten
versorgt haben dann gibt es da noch
saudi-arabische Verantwortliche für den
Krieg in Jemen mit immerhin 400.000
Toten nächstes Beispiel Aserbaidschan
einer der Geldgeber einzelner
unionsabgeordneter die haben gerade
Krieg in Armenien geführt ich erinnere
auch daran dass der dritte Irakkrieg
nach herrschender Meinung als
völkerrechtswidrig bewertet wird
mindestens 100.000 Menschen starben
warum hat damals nicht der wertewesten
Colin Paul sanktioniert oder den
britischen Premier Toni Blair oder oder
Doppelmoral wohin man nur schaut merken
sie was sie müssten die halbe Welt
sanktionieren
falls Sie aber Vorhaben die Sanktionen
auf Russen zu beschränken kommt sofort
zurecht die Rassismuskeule
zum Gesetz selber es steht ein relativ
großer erfüllungsaufwand von 100
Millionen Euro einmalig und 85 Millionen
Euro jährlich im Raum ich gehe mit ihnen
jede Wetter ein dass die Einnahmen aus
diesem Gesetz kleiner sein werden als
die erfüllungsaufwände die Deutschland
hat was macht mich da eigentlich so
zuversichtlich im besten Deutschland
aller Zeiten im Land des
vorzeigeprojektes Flughafen BER wollen
sie zwei neue Behörden schaffen eine
Zentralstelle für sanktionsdurchsetzung
auf Bundesebene und ein
Verwaltungsverfahren mit Register zu
Ermittlung von Vermögen sanktionierter
Personen
bis diese beiden Behörden endlich
arbeitsfähig sind sind die Vermögen
schon längst über alle Berge wie sagte
schon Karl Marx Kapital ist ein scheues
Reh das Kapital wird dann also irgendwo
in Asien und Afrika investiert nur nicht
bei uns in Deutschland
es wird so kommen wie bei den
Gaslieferungen die Sanktionen Schaden
Deutschland mehr als Russland
für uns von Alternative für Deutschland
erhebt sich grundsätzlich die Frage ob
wir Personen die keinerlei Straftaten
begangen haben die auch nicht mit
internationalem Haftbefehl gesucht
werden überhaupt sanktionieren sollten
Eigentumsrechte zu schützen ist einer
der wichtigsten Vorteile des Westens
diese Rechte gelten für uns als
universell dieser Eigentumsschutz hat
bei uns auch durch Artikel 14
Grundgesetz Verfassungsrang
man konnte bisher bisher konnte man
darauf vertrauen dass man als Individuum
beurteilt würde egal woher man kam und
wie man aussah denn einer der
wichtigsten Grundsätze westlicher
Rechtsstaaten ist es dass es so etwas
wie ein kollektives Verbrechen oder auch
eine kollektive Bestrafung nicht gibt
meine Damen und Herren mit diesen
Sanktionen wird sich immer ein Grund
finden Vermögen zu beschlagnahmen
und damit ist das Vertrauen in den
Westen ein für alle Mal weltweit dahin
die Anhängerschaft des Westens wird sich
bei dieser Heuchelei und bei dieser
Doppelmoral deutlich verkleinern
das ist eine dramatische Entwicklung
schon allein deshalb weil jetzt jeder
chinesische Tycoon jeder indische Stahl
Milliardär jeder vermögende weltweit
sich einfach fragen wird ob er
vielleicht als nächstes sanktioniert
wird wenn seine Regierung spinnt diese
Sanktionen werden langfristig ein
Bumerang vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
Björn König sagte hier unter anderem
dass die Sanktionen Deutschland mehr
schaden würden als russland hat sich
dementsprechend dagegen
ausgesprochen auf ihn folgten und
Franziska Brandner
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren mit dem zweiten
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz schaffen
wir jetzt dauerhafte Strukturen für eine
schlagkräftige sanktionsdurchsetzung die
Neuerungen wurden genannt die
Zentralstelle für die
sanktionsdurchsetzung
Verwaltungsverfahren zur Ermittlung des
Register zu gelisteten Personen und
Vermögenswerten und der Hauer sie haben
jetzt hier gesagt das ist ja so spät im
November wissen sie hatten 16 Jahre Zeit
dazu
und wenn Sie in diesem Fall ist es
wirklich nur der Hauer wissen Sie wann
die ersten Ukraine Sanktionen
verabschiedet wurden das war 2014 nach
der Annexion der Krims und wenn ich sie
dran erinnern darf war der
Finanzminister zu dieser Zeit ein
Finanzminister der CDU und hat damals
nichts unternommen um die
sanktionsdurchsetzungen in Deutschland
zu verstärken und durchzusetzen das ist
die Realität und es ist gut dass wir es
jetzt endlich tun
[Applaus]
und
es wir bekämpfen es der Finanzminister
war der CDU ja und ich finde es ist ganz
schön unverschämt aus dem Glashaus zu
schmeißen wenn man selber ganz schön
fette drin sitzt
ach so und wir bekämpfen die Geldwäsche
hier mit aller Entschlossenheit wir
führen endlich ein barzahlungsverbot bei
Immobilientransaktionen ein es ist Zeit
dass Oligarchen egal wo sie herkommt
ihre Willen nicht mehr bei uns aus dem
Geldkoffer bezahlen können das ist
endlich vorbei Mafia Steuerbetrüger
Oligarchen sie alle haben in der
Vergangenheit profitiert von den
Defiziten der Bekämpfung von Geldwäsche
und Finanzkriminalität in Deutschland
das hat jüngst wieder der OECD für den
Financial Action Task Force Bericht ganz
klar für Deutschland offengelegt und
hier werden wir auch nicht locker lassen
wir werden deswegen noch weitere
Reformen angehen um diese
internationalen Empfehlungen auch
endlich umzusetzen und ja wenn die
Eigentümer von Vermögensgegenständen
bewusst verschleiert werden wenn sie
nicht erkennbar gemacht werden dann muss
in letzter Konsequenz auch ein Entzug
des Eigentums möglich sein und Herr
Hauer dann zählen wir natürlich da auf
Ihre Unterstützung und Zustimmung dafür
wenn es jetzt dann auch zeitnah kommt
meine Damen und Herren mit dem
vorgelegten Gesetz verbessern wir die
sanktionsdurchsetzung in Deutschland
grundlegend und es ist deswegen ein
guter Tag weil wir damit ein Beitrag
dazu leisten nicht nur für uns den
Rechtsstaat bei uns in Deutschland zu
verbessern sondern Freiheit und
Demokratie in Europa an der Seite der
Ukraine wirklich nachhaltig unterstützen
zu können in dem Sinne bitte ich sie um
ihre Unterstützung für das Gesetz danke
soweit die Parlamentarische
Staatssekretärin aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium Franziska
Brandner für die Linksfraktion wird nun
Pascal Meiser sprechen
das war der letzte Kollege Pascal Meiser
Fraktion kein Problem
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine Damen
und Herren noch immer ist Deutschland
ein sicherer Hafen für schmutziges Geld
aus aller Welt und die schleppende
Umsetzung der Sanktionen gegen russische
Oligarchen hat einmal besonders deutlich
gemacht Deutschland hat nicht nur ein
massives
transparenzdefizits wenn es darum geht
wem welche Unternehmen Immobilien und
andere große Vermögen tatsächlich
gehören Deutschland hat auch ein
erhebliches vollzugsdefiz zieht bei der
Bekämpfung von Geldwäsche genauso beim
Einfrieren von Vermögen sanktionierter
Oligarchen mit diesen unsäglichen
Zuständen muss jetzt endlich schluss
gemacht werden meine Damen und Herren
als Fraktion DIE LINKE haben wir dazu
bereits vor gut drei Jahren in
umfassenden Masterplan vorgelegt das ist
wirklich ärgerlich dass sie damalige
große Koalition aus Union im SPD darauf
damals nicht adäquat reagiert hat mit
dem heute vorliegenden Gesetzentwurf
verspricht die Bundesregierung nun den
großen Wurf um anzugehen was Wolfgang
Schäuble Olaf Scholz als Finanzminister
nacheinander über 16 Jahre ausgesetzt
oder blockiert haben aber es ist
wirklich der große Wurf auch in
Deutschland soll nun als letzten Land in
der Europäischen Union verboten werden
dass man Immobilien mit einem Koffer
voll schmutzigen Bargeld kaufen kann gut
so richtig so sie greifen auch endlich
unsere Forderungen auf das
Transparenzregister mit den über 500
Grundbüchern im ganzen Land zu
verknüpfen auch das begrüßen wir
natürlich und es ist längst überfällig
den Schätzungen zu folgen werden allein
15 bis 30 Prozent aller inkriminierten
Vermögenswerte in Immobilien gesteckt
und ja sie kommen endlich den Wunsch der
Bundesländer nach die Zuständigkeit bei
der Durchsetzung von Sanktionen zu
bündeln auf den Bund zu übertragen
allein meine Damen und Herren dabei zu
bleiben ob diese Maßnahmen alleine
ausreichen und das offensichtlich nicht
nur bei uns sondern auch in reine
Bundesregierung Staatssekretär gigold
aus dem Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft
und Klimaschutz hat mit Blick auf den
Gesetzentwurf geschrieben in seinem
Newsletter nachzulesen auf seiner
Webseite ich zitiere im Kampf gegen
Geldwäsche und organisierter
Kriminalität ist also noch viel Luft
nach oben Zitat Ende recht hat er
deshalb bessern Sie hier im weiteren
Gesetzgebungsverfahren nach zunächst
auch weiterhin drücken sich davor auch
die private Nutzung von sanktionierten
und eingefrorenen Vermögen zu untersagen
es ist und bleibt aber niemand zu
vermitteln dass ein Oligarchen in
Deutschland zwar untersagt ist eine
viertwiller in Berlin Zehlendorf oder am
Starnberger See zu vermieten er sie aber
weiterhin uneingeschränkt legal privat
nutzen darf zweitens sorgen Sie dafür
dass aus den transparenzregistern
tatsächlich für alle Unternehmen
hervorgeht wer tatsächlich die
wirtschaftlich Berechtigten sind wir
brauchen dringend eine systematische und
risikorentierte Überwachung der
transparenzregistereinträge nach dem
Vorbild Österreichs drittens unter sagen
Sie nicht nur die Barzahlung bei ihrem
Immobiliengeschäften sondern führen Sie
auch eine bargeldobergrenze für große
Vermögensgeschäfte im gesamten nicht
Finanzsektor ein wo die Risiken für
Geldwäsche nicht minder groß und
viertens schaffen sie eine
Rechtsgrundlage dafür im Zweifel
verdächtiges Vermögen dessen Herkunft
ungeklärt ist beschlagnahmen zu können
so wie dies zum Beispiel Großbritannien
mit der anexplant-welve Order vormacht
meine Damen und Herren ich komme zum
Schluss tatsächlich kommen wir nur so
wenn wir all diese Maßnahmen ergreifen
zu einer effektiven Bekämpfung von
Geldwäsche nur so treffen wir am Ende
auch diejenigen die wie die russischen
Oligarchen oder das iranische
mullerregime Teil ihres Vermögens im
sicheren Hafen Deutschland geparkt haben
dort wo es ihnen ernsthaft wehtut und
das bleibt weiter dringend geboten
vielen Dank
Pascal Meiser hat hier natürlich auch
noch mal die Machthaber des Irans
angesprochen auch darüber haben wir ja
schon die Abgeordneten am Mittwoch
debattiert wie da Sanktionen auch
EU-weit besser durchgesetzt werden
können Sebastian Fiedler spricht jetzt
für die SPD-Fraktion er Sprecher für
Kriminalpolitik
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren
ich versuche so ein bisschen mal in der
Historie zu rütteln und das ganze Thema
noch ein bisschen einzuordnen das hat
den Vorteil dass ich auch die Union an
das ein oder andere aus der
Vergangenheit vielleicht erinnern kann
ich arbeite dieses Thema nämlich noch
aus verschiedenen Funktionen beim Bund
Deutscher Kriminalbeamter seit fast 13
Jahren inzwischen und habe noch ein
präzises Gedächtnis daran welche Rolle
Wolfgang Schäuble bei der
Geldwäschebekämpfung so eingenommen hat
und deswegen ist wirklich bemerkenswert
was sie da aufgeschrieben haben ich
komme danach noch drauf zu sprechen
ich habe noch
wahnsinnig gute Erinnerungen daran wie
der Trilog in Brüssel gelaufen ist als
es darum ging ein Transparenzregister
einzuführen und ich weiß noch welches
Ministerium in Brüssel mit allen Kräften
auf der Bremse gestanden habe um
überhaupt ein Transparenzregister
einzuführen das ist alles ganz
bemerkenswert was sie da aufgeschrieben
haben aber ich will zunächst einmal das
Thema Sanktionen durchaus noch mal in
ein ehrliches und offenes Licht richten
weil richtigerweise sie haben die
richtige Verordnung rausgesucht die zur
Krim ist tatsächlich schon aus dem Jahr
2014 269 ist die Nummer wer Interesse
daran hat das noch mal nachzugucken zwei
Suchbegriffe Bundesbank und Sanktionen
der findet ich glaube inzwischen 30
sanktions Regime und als ich mich jetzt
in unserer Arbeitsgruppe wir haben in
der SPD-Fraktion als einziger eine
Arbeitsgruppe Kriminalpolitik
eingerichtet die sich übergreifen mit
solchen Fragen schon im März beschäftigt
hat und festgestellt hat tatsächlich
dass wir überhaupt keine gescheiten
Rechtsgrundlagen haben ich habe Gruppe
festgestellt ich habe von keiner
politischen Partei das ist die Wahrheit
in der Vergangenheit Initiativen finden
können ich habe keine kritischen
Journalisten gefunden den der
Vergangenheit darüber berichtet hatten
ich habe in der Wissenschaft kaum
jemanden gefunden der sich mit den
Sanktionen beschäftigt das ist die
Wahrheit und das in dieses Licht gehört
sozusagen alle Vorhaben die wir jetzt
heute besprechen gerückt
und wir haben uns natürlich auch
angeguckt wie das woanders ist in den
USA gibt es die Opfer des Officer Foren
Assets control es gibt in Italien die
gerade die Finanzen die immer mal wieder
zurecht besprochen wird und wir kommen
ich komme gleich auf einige Aspekte dann
noch zu sprechen wenn die Zeit reicht
und wir müssen den zweiten Kontext
aufmachen und das ist eine gute Brücke
zu den richtigen hinweisen die der
Bundesfinanzminister vorhin hier
aufgemacht hat etwa 100 Milliarden Euro
werden hier jedes Jahr kriminell
erwirtschaftet und der Staat sieht
weniger als ein Prozent davon und jetzt
wollen wir alle nicht in der Haut des
Bundesfinanzministers stecken wenn der
historisch größte Staatsausgaben zu
organisieren hat jeder einzelne Euro ist
wahnsinnig wichtig aber der Zusammenhang
dass wir 99 Prozent davon liegen lassen
ist in der Tat die größte
ungerechtigkeitslücke überhaupt und
deswegen sollten wir alle die
Reformbereitschaft die der
Bundesfinanzminister hier mutig an den
Tag legt mal so würdigen wie es sich
gehört weil solche Reform die jetzt hier
gerade auf Vorschlägen haben wir seit
Jahrzehnten nicht gesehen in der
Geldwäschebekämpfung und schon gar nicht
von der Union heraus
und
nötig ist und dass wir das richtig
machen da würde ich mal sagen da gilt
die große Überschrift Gründlichkeit vor
Schnelligkeit daran werden Sie sehen und
das sehen sie auch es ist ja schon
dokumentiert dass das erste Schritte
sind und weiter sind und dass wir
natürlich an verdächtiges Vermögen in
seit März arbeiten wir in der Fraktion
da schon das Bundesfinanzminister
Justizministerium die ganze
Bundesregierung arbeitet an einem
rechtsstaatlich sicheren Konzept und ich
kann wirklich nicht anders und ich komme
auf meine Anfang der Rede noch mal
zurück meine Verwunderung zum Ausdruck
bringen und der Applaus der linken und
ihr gemeinsamer Applaus hat wirklich
alles gezeigt während ich gestern hier
am Puls stand und gedacht habe das
machen sie ja auch im Innenbereich schon
mal mit gleichen Überschriften zu
Anträgen zur AFD wo sie versuchen die
Regierung irgendwo rechts zu überholen
mit ihren Themen schärfere Strafen und
so weiter mit diesem Antrag versuchen
sie aber ganz links jetzt an der Spur
vorbeizukommen weil sie tatsächlich
lustigerweise zwar zollpolizei
draufgeschrieben haben weil das sind
Programme die der Linken Parteitage
kommen die Partei das Beschlüsse der SPD
schon zu ihrem Antrag sage ich sehr viel
sie müssen nur zuhören dann hätten sie
die Inhalte erkannt das hätte ihm
geholfen
[Applaus]
der entscheidend der entscheidende Punkt
den wir jetzt machen und da muss man
eben dran arbeiten dann müssen Sie nicht
den Leuten erzählen nachdem was ich
ihnen gerade gesagt habe dass wir
Jahrzehnte hier nachholen müssen
tatsächlich und ich habe Herr Schäuble
als ein prominentes Beispiel für die
Bremsen hier genannt da ist es wichtig
ein Satz er konnte das nicht wissen dass
ich mir den schon aufgeschrieben habe
sie haben nämlich schon 2017 mit dem
Satz aufgewartet der Staat muss die
Sicherheit besser organisieren als die
Verbrecher und es ist ein kluger Satz
und deswegen müssen wir tatsächlich bei
den neuen Strukturen auch bedenken und
gut daran arbeiten dass wir hier
ermittlungsorganisationen brauchen mit
neuen Instrumenten um dieses ein Prozent
signifikant zu steigern um mehr
schmutziges Geld in die Finger zu
kriegen was übrigens Opfern und dem
Staat gehört je nachdem welcher
Sachverhalt das ist und dann glaube ich
kriegen wir vor diesem Hintergrund
tatsächlich etwas hin was an Reformen
diese Republik soll noch nicht gesehen
hat und das kann man sagen an alle
Mafiosi und Schwerverbrecher und
Steuerhinterzieher ziehen Sie sich warm
an
für die cdu/csu-fraktion hat nun Carsten
Müller das Wort
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren ich will mal den
Beitrag meines Vorredners zum Anlass
nehmen ich finde das ehrlich gesagt eine
ziemlich Vermessenheit das zeigt aber
auch wie weit sie von der Realität
entrückt sind dass sie versuchen
dass sie versuchen ja wir kriegen es ja
auch ab und zu mal Sie wie Sie versuchen
die Union und die sogenannte AFD in
Eintopf zu rühren ich finde also wenn
das ihr intellektueller Anspruch ist
dann müsst das würde man früher mit
einem Offenbarungseid beantworten müssen
sie müssen sich ihre Rede noch mal
durchlesen ist nicht das erste Mal
möglicherweise möglicherweise ist das
ein bisschen Liebedienerei gegenüber
ihrem Parteivorsitzenden aber das muss
an dieser Stelle angesprochen werden
meine Damen und Herren die Grundzüge
dass die Grundzüge des Vorschlags der
Regierung und der koalitionsfraktion
sind nicht verkehrt wir haben
wesentliche Teile dieser Grundzüge
bereits in einem Antrag in diesem Haus
am im Mai diesen Jahres besprochen und
wenn wir uns dann allerdings und da will
ich keinesfalls mich sozusagen in das in
das Fahrwasser der rückblickskoalition
begeben sondern einfach mal eine
Bestandsaufnahme machen wenn wir uns
anschauen was bisher geleistet worden
ist dann müssen wir objektiv feststellen
das ist zu wenig gewesen in Deutschland
sie haben möglicherweise aus dem kleinen
Luxemburg gehört dass die mit stand
gestern
5,5 Milliarden Euro
russisches oligarchengeld eingefroren
haben gestern um 10.58 Uhr ging die
Meldung über den Ticker das
Großbritannien jetzt außerhalb der EU
rund 20 Milliarden Euro im Gegenwert
eingefroren hat die Erfolg in
Deutschland nehmen sich aus unserer
Sicht deutlich zu regnen aus dabei geht
es um nichts weniger als diesen
russischen Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
mit allen Mitteln die wir haben
rechtsstaatlich zu beantworten und
entschlossen zu beantworten und diesen
unsäglichen Zivilisationsbruch nicht um
sanktioniert zu lassen dazu vielleicht
noch eine letzte und einzige Ausführung
zu dem Beitrag der von der sogenannten
AFD kam da wurde ja bemängelt dass das
reaktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz zu wenig
Einnahmen in die kassenspiele da kann
ich Ihnen nur sagen also wenn sie
einnahmenerwartung an
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz haben dann
haben sie offensichtlich den
Gesamtkomplex überhaupt nicht umrissen
und verstanden empfehle da noch mal ein
bisschen nachzuarbeiten wir sind
gespannt auf die Ausführungen in den
weiteren Beratungen meine Damen und
Herren der SPD-Kollege zuvor hat die
Tatkraft der Bundesregierung gelobt wir
schauen mal auf diese strafbewährte
Anzeigepflicht Pflicht auf die sie
abgehoben haben dann müssen nämlich von
den Sanktionen
betroffene Personen natürliche und
juristische
gelter und wirtschaftliche Ressourcen
angeben und sich anzeigen
sie haben die Regelung geschaffen in den
ersten Monaten ging nicht eine einzige
Anzeige ein das ist doch führt doch
vollkommen ins Leere das müssen sie doch
erkennen wenn Sie eine Maßnahme
Standorten mit 0 Ergebnis ist die
Maßnahme nicht richtig und meine Damen
und Herren das zieht sich leider durch
ihre bisherige Handhabung wir haben wir
haben gesehen dass sie die Kommunen bei
der sanktionsdurchsetzung in die erste
Reihe schieben wollen mittlerweile
merken Sie auch dass das nicht
funktioniert hat wir brauchen eine
einheitliche stark ausgestattete
zollpolizei dann können wir die können
wir die Sanktionen durchsetzen und zwar
schlagkräftig und verknüpft und ehrlich
gesagt zum Thema wie wir den
Datenabgleich machen auch
grenzüberschreitend haben sie keine
probaten Vorschläge nichts Fehlanzeige
sie in dem Moment in dem Oligarchen
international agieren gehen die bei
ihnen gar nicht ins Netz rein und das
kann so nicht bleiben meine Damen und
Herren
ich hatte was zur zollpolizei gesagt die
wir fordern ich hatte was dazu gesagt
dass wir bereits im Mai
spazahlungsverbot bei Immobilienkäufen
gefordert haben das findet sich jetzt
die Einbindung internationelle
Informationssysteme ist ein wichtiges
Thema und wir müssen insofern einen
weiteren wichtigen Punkt in meinen
Kollegen Matthias Hauer richtigerweise
angesprochen hat entschlossen angehen
nämlich bei Vermögen aus ungeklärter
Herkunft eine vollumfängliche
Beweislastumkehr einführen das ist das
schärfste Schwert das wir haben und dann
würde und wir haben ja hier ein bisschen
was erlebt es wird wahrscheinlich die
zuhören und Zuhörer ein bisschen bei
Fremden nach dem Motto haust du meine
Tante haue ich deine Tante sie haben ein
bisschen das unerfreuliche Thema Masken
die jetzt angesprochen wir haben das
Thema
212.000 Euro in bar gefunden bei ihrem
vormaligen haushaltspolitischen Sprecher
einem ihren engen Fahrensmann des
Bundeskanzlers Johannes Kaas hat das
sozusagen mal auf die Seite gebracht
vielleicht als so eine Art privates
Schonvermögen um beim Thema Bürgergeld
noch zu bleiben also er schon sich in
erster Linie selber meine Damen und
Herren wir müssen diese Beweislastumkehr
kurzfristig umsetzen wir als Union
wollen das und wenn wir uns auf diese
Themen des konzentrieren kriegen wir
womöglich ich empfehle Ihnen sehr auf
die auch Vorschläge der Union zu achten
eine vernünftige Regelung hin es darf
nämlich eines nicht gelten und das
vielmehr noch beim Blick auf die
Stimmungslage in den
Koalitionsfraktionen ein bei ihnen ist
die Stimmung stets besser als die
Leistung das sehen sie zwar anders aber
die Bevölkerung sieht es genauso vielen
Dank
Carsten Müller war das hier anfangs auch
mit sehr deutlichen Worten
an den
gerichtet und damit kommen wir zum
letzten Redner in dieser Debatte das ist
der rechtspolitische Sprecher von
Bündnis 90 die Grünen im Deutschen
Bundestag hey gelimburg vielen Dank Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Herr Kollege Müller sie haben davon
gesprochen dass sie eine
Bestandsaufnahme über das bisher
erreichte der Koalition machen wollen
und dann folgte ein Rückblick was
nämlich angeblich alles unzureichendes
passiert ist sagen wir mal so Herr
Müller wir sind uns doch sicherlich
einig dass diese Koalition in einem
dreiviertel Jahr im Bereich der
Geldwäschebekämpfung der Transparenz der
sanktionsdurchsetzung viel viel mehr
geschafft hat als die unionsgeführten
Bundesregierung in 16 Jahren
aber
für Sie erhauer und auch für mich gilt
ja das Zitat
von von Konrad Adenauer nichts hindert
uns daran klüger zu werden
selbstverständlich ich begrüße dass sie
das letzte Dreivierteljahr genutzt haben
und ich sage Ihnen
wir alle sollten miteinander immer
schauen wo wir noch effektiver werden
können
nur einen Punkt kann sogar auch nicht
stehen bleiben Herr Kollege Müller wenn
sie behaupten wir würden im Bereich des
Informationsaustausches mit
ausländischen Stellen überhaupt nichts
machen dann empfehle ich Ihnen das hätte
ich einen Blick ins Gesetz Paragraph 8
des sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetze
triggert ganz klar den
Informationsaustausch mit ausländischen
stellen und zwar auch hier unter klarem
transparenten rechtsstaatlichen
datenschutzkonform Voraussetzung aber
eben auch effektiv und schnell und zügig
ich weiß nicht wo dann noch Raum für
ihre Kritik ist Liebe
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir gehen
mit diesem Gesetz diesen Gesetzespaket
einen großen Schritt vorwärts der bei
der Durchsetzung von Sanktionen es gibt
konkrete ermittlungsbefugnisse keine
strafrechtlichen aber doch Strafrecht
ähnlichen oder Strafprozess recht
ähnlichen ermittlungsbefugnissen zur
Herstellung zu Ermittlung von
sanktioniertem Vermögen hier in
Deutschland wir schaffen in der Tat eine
zentrale Stelle aber klar ist dass diese
zentrale Stelle die Arbeit nicht alleine
leistet sondern dass es uns gelingen
muss eine effektive Zusammenarbeit der
Behörden im Kommunen Ländern Bund
europäische Behörden und
behördenausländischer Staaten
sicherzustellen und zu gewährleisten ich
habe Zweifel dass die einfache Forderung
nach einer ganz großen Bundesbehörde die
hat alles alleine machen soll
tatsächlich in der Praxis sich bewähren
würde liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Union
meine Damen und Herren wir verbieten
dass es angesprochen worden endlich den
Erwerb von Immobilien mit Bargeld oder
kryptowährung und der Finanzminister es
ist sie haben ja davon gesprochen dass
die personen die Immobilien mit Bargeld
bezahlen nicht Freiheit im Sinn haben
vielleicht haben die schon irgendeine
Form von Freiheit und sind aber ich
glaube sie haben nicht die Freiheit die
wir meinen sind wir wollen natürlich die
Freiheit auch mit Bargeld zu bezahlen
sicherstellen aber in einem
rechtsstaatlichen Rahmen und deswegen
ist es richtig dass wir an dieser Stelle
an dieser Stelle den Gebrauch von
Bargeld einschränken ohne ihm
grundsätzlich anzutasten liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
meine Damen und Herren in der Tat im
Entschließungsantrag der Union sind
einige interessante Forderungen drin die
so oder so ähnlich in anderen Staaten
der Europäischen Union realisiert sind
wenn man an beweist das Umkehren andere
Dinge denkt und wir sollten uns die
ausschussberatung tatsächlich Zeit
nehmen zu überprüfen an welchen Stellen
wir im Gesetzentwurf noch besser werden
können nur liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen so einfach wie sie das hier
darstellen beweist das Umkehr Vermögen
was sanktioniertes komplett ein Ziel
unter anderweitig weiter verwerten so
einfach und das wissen sie in Wahrheit
auch ist es eben nicht wir befinden uns
hier nicht im Bereich wir befinden uns
eben nicht im Bereich einer
strafrechtlichen Verurteilung von
sondern von Sanktionierungen wir wollen
mit rechtsstaatlichen Mitteln die
Oligarchen bekämpfen
und dabei so weit gehen wie wir können
aber eben auch nicht weiter als dass der
Rechtsstaat zulässt vielen Dank
ich schließe die Aussprache
interfraktionell wird Überweisung der
Vorlagen auf den Drucksachen
4.326 und
4340 an die in der Tagesordnung
aufgeführten Ausschüsse vorgeschlagen